مساء الخير
سنه 2020 لما حصلت جائحه الكورونا 19 حصل
كارثه بشريه على مستوى العالم مش كارثه
بشريه بس ولكن كارثه اقتصاديه شركات كتير
جدا خرجت من السوق شركات كتير جدا غيرت
نشاطاتها وشركات كتير صرحت اكتر من 50 ل
60% من موظفينها
شكل الكاريير في العالم كله اتغير من موظف
لابس البدله
وماسك الشنطه بتاعته تحول لموظف قاعد بنص
البدله وبنطلون البيجامه وقاعد على زوم
في الوقت ده حصل انتعاشه غريبه جدا في سوق
موازي
بس بيدي عملت احصائيه بتقول مين اكتر دوله
كانت اكثر استقرارا في الوقت ده اقتصاديا
وطبعا كانت الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
تعالوا ننط نطه كده الاقتصاد امريكا لو
فاكت غريبه جدا
5% من اقتصاد امريكا معتمد على
الفيلانسينج احد اكبر منصات العمل الحر في
العالم كله عملت احصائيه سنه 2020 سنه
الكوفيد 19 لقيت ان 75 مليون امريكي كسب
واحد تريليون دولار في سنه كان اقتصاد
العالم كله بيقع
الحقيقه الشركات بدات تدرس ده على مستوى
ولقت ان ده اكثر توفيرا للشركه فبدل موظف
في مكان بياخد سبيس في الشركه وكنت بتضطر
ان انت تدفعله ساعات اجريت ترانسفورتيشن
او التنقل وبتضطر تديه مرتب ثابت كل شهر
ريجاردليس
في توقعاتها قالت في سنه 2023 هيحصل من
الشركات يعني او انتاج الشركات هيحصل له
اوت سور بنسبه
373%
متوقع طبعا ان هو يزداد بشكل كبير في
السنوات اللي جايه
الارقام بتقول ان اقتصاد العالم دلوقتي
هيتحرك في اتجاه
على مستوى الافراد في سنه 2020 برضو احد
منصات العمل الحر عملت فضي لطيفه جدا
اسمها
سالت الناس هل انتم عايزين تستقلوا
الغريب ان عشره مليون امريكي قالوا ان
احنا
والاغرب ان 53% منهم قالوا احنا عايزين
ريزاين عشان نبقى
مع ان المشهور عن ان هو اقل استقرارا
ماديا
سالوا سؤال تاني سالوا الناس ليه عايزين
تكونوا
طب اعلى اجابتين واحد
اكسب فلوس اكتر السبب التاني كان اكسبلور
مور كارير اوبشنز اشوف كارير تاني الغريب
والصادم في الدراسه دي ان لقوا الناس اللي
اختاروا اختيار ده كان اعمارهم اواخر
العشرينات لنص التلاتين
الغريب ان المفروض ان في السن ده اتخرجنا
من الكليه عملنا
بدانا نترقى ليه ممكن حد في السن ده يقرر
انه يغير الكبير بتاعه
في دراسه موازيه في نفس السنه عملتها
بتقول هل الانسان لما اشتغل ريموتي او
فيلنسنج كان اكثر استقرارا كان اكثر سعاده
ونتائج برضو كان الصادمه
الفاميلي باندينج زاد
الاستقرار والبويكس فاكشن زاد في سنه
او العنف الاسري قالب نسبه ايه بوينت في
امريكا
الحقيقه الارقام دي كلها سواء كانت على
المستوى النفسي او على مستوى البرفشنال
خليتنا احس ان انا
ver
انا اتحركت من كليه طب بشري سنه 2009 كليه
يحلم بها ناس كتير جدا
قضيت سنه الامتياز
قضيت سنه ونص في كارير السيتري نفسي
وبعدين قدمت استقالتي في وزاره الصحه
وقررت
في فتره كان يمكن مش مشهور قوي اشتغلت في
احد الكبير اللي انا بحبها جدا هي الترجمه
الطبيه اللي جمعت ما بين الحاجه اللي انا
بحب اعملها ودراستي
الحقيقه اللي دخلني من الفلنسنج كان فعليا
40 ضعف الانكوم اللي كنت هاخده من الكبير
الاصلي بتاعي بحلول سنه 2017 اسست
اون بيزنس
وحاليا في 2023 ولا في عمر ال 37 انا انجل
او مستثمر لمشاريع ان شاء الله هتطرح في
الخليج السنه دي
[تصفيق]
الحقيقه التجربه الانسانيه بحكيها دي مش
تضربها فريده من نوعها لما بدات احتك
بالكثير من رواد الاعمال الفتره الاخيره
لقيت معظمه خريجين طب صيدله هندسه كليات
قمه كليات ناس كتير تحلم بها ولكن الحقيقه
ومعاشوش
لايف ستايل او بروفيشنال
كارير كان المجتمع هيفرضوا عليهم ولكن
قرروا بناء على الارقام
ان هم يلاقوا الشعب بتاعهم ويتبعوه
انا عارفه ان في منكم كتير دلوقتي بيقولوا
هعمل كده ازاي في احد نظريات مثلث الثراء
اللي بتقول لك ازاي تبقى ثري ان يكون عندك
مهاره واحده المهاره دي تعمل لها مانيطه
تحولها لفلوس طب هعرف المهاره بتاعتي ازاي
اول السبت هي السلف اكسبلور اكتشاف الذات
اكتشف انا بحب ايه انا بميل لايه انا بعرف
اعمل ايه احنا دلوقتي هنتحول الى عالم
مهاري الشركات دلوقتي مش هتسالك انت خليه
كليه ايه انت خبرتك ايه ولكن الشركات
هتسالك انت بتعرف تعمل ايه اتمنى النهارده
شكرا لكم
[تصفيق]